hello guys I'm here with our US Champion
Nakamura a very nice outfit you got on
today what was the occasion
I think everyone dressed up his first
round major tournament so it's just how
it goes so what do you think about
today's game um well I don't know I mean
I think I was a little bit lucky in the
opening Alexander played his King itch
to which I don't know if it's a novelty
I feel like I've seen it before but at
any rate I didn't think I played the
right way I didn't think see if I was
necessarily best but um okay I think
they're in the middle game I was gonna
write a few bad moves and I was able to
get in this f5 move and after that I
think I'm probably much better and then
I basically I played the wrong order I
mean I should have just taken this pawn
on g4 instead of going g6 first because
basically as it turns out in the game or
at least I think there wasn't quite
enough to win it looks so much better
but it's just not simple so if I'd gone
the other way I would have just had a
lasting advantage whereas I thought I
possibly could have won on the spot with
the way I played with g6 but I mean
sometimes things don't go your way and
that's just life that's right you look
pretty composed you're not too
disappointed it's that's how it goes
sometimes I mean you win some you lose
some
I mean today was a draw but okay I was
black so it's certainly not not the end
of the world so London I have read
before that you said you love the city
what is it that you like so much about
London I just like the atmosphere it
reminds me a lot of New York City
actually there are a lot of different
areas a lot of a lot of good food
especially you know ethnic food Indian
Iranian and so forth obviously here in
Kensington and it's just a great city
obviously there are a lot of tourist
attractions as well so I really like it
of course the drawback is it's too
expensive you know the currency exchange
rate and also it gets dark much too
early but otherwise it's a great city
you know I enjoy being here we'll just
win the grand gesture pay for all
[ __ ] Leslie mostly I'm not thinking
about money right now all right thank
you
thanks guys back to the studio